ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN BURKE CALDERON
CORREO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORP MARK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TEAM BALLOT ERRORS V.
APPROVED WELL VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
AND HAND.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THESE PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
. THE IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YES
SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD. I PRAY TO YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR STATES
LAWMAKERS AND FOR THE DISTRICTS
THEY REPRESENT. I PRAY THAT YOU
GRANT THEM A SPIRIT OF WISDOM
INSIGHT AND COOPERATION. I PRAY
THAT YOU HELP THEM TO SERVE THE
STATE AND ITS BEST INTERESTS. I
PRAY THAT WE LEARN TO LOVE ONE
ANOTHER. AS CALIFORNIANS. SO
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE PEACE AND
JUSTICE TEMPERED WITH MERCY.
THANK YOU FOR THE FREEDOM THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS NATION. I THANK
YOU FOR THE PROTECTION AND
PROVISION. YOU HAVE PLACED OVER
US AS YOUR BLESSINGS I MEAN.
THANK YOU MY BEST SIR WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
KALRA. PLEASE JOIN ME FOR THE-
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE-
UNITED STATES- YEAH- THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
TRIMMER SACRAMENTO FRIDAY
JANUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
TO THE ASSEMBLY REDDIT NINE AM
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TMPORE UV SIMPLY PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK FOR PART OF A DEATH
CHIEF CLERK SHE BROUGHT IN
PROCOL ROSE CALLED. ONE OF THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
WERE ABLE TO QUORUM CALL THE
ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRIED TIME
MODIFY REYES. AND MISTER FLORA.
SECONDS AT THE OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S BE TO. WITH PRESS. AND
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVIE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
AND MS
RAYOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE HELLO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MEDINA SMITH BLOOM CHOI NGUYEN
AND DAVIES TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE OH TWO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE TO THE INACTIVE FILE
. THE CLERK WILL KNOW. MEMBERS
TODAY IS A SPECIAL DAY FOR THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW. WE ARE IN
SESSION ON THE BIRTHDAY OF OUR
MAJORITY LEADER ELOISE RADIUS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING HER A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. SEVERAL MEMBERS
. SEVERAL AUTHORS HAVE
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THOSE
AMENDMENTS AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN MR HOLDEN WILL
CIRCLE BACK TO THAT. FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE WE'RE TAKING OF
AMENDMENTS AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE IS AB. EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER LEE. CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE MISTER LEE ON THE M.
S. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE IT EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT AB
BYE FOR SMALL. BOB LANDLORDS
THIS AMENDMENT MAY CLEAR THAT WE
DO NOT INTENDED. SMALL ONE POINT
LANDLORDS OF THIS REFORM BUT THE
LARGE CORPORATE REAL ESTATE
MOGULS THAT ARE BUYING UP RENT
CONTROL BUILDINGS THANK YOU.
AFTER I'VE OF. THANK YOU MISLI
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. HI
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT
THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE. NEXT
UP FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX IS AB
FORTINO SIX BY MR LACKEY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN OH SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY. MISTER LACK ANY
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB.
SCARES ME FORTINO. UNDER CURRENT
LAW PEACE OFFICERS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO CARRY THEIR
FIREARMS. AND TASER ON SEPARATE
AREAS OF THE PERSON. THIS IS
LEAD TO UNNECESSARY COULD FREEZE
FOR ACTION. CHARGE IN PLACE OF
THE TRADE. ALL GRANT LOS LIFE IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE WHEN OFFICERS
. GRABS FIREARM OVERSTAY. IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA. MOST NOTABLY
LATE AS OF LATE DANTE RIGHT
TRAGICALLY LOST HIS LIFE WHEN
OFFICERS SHOT IN DISCHARGING
WHAT SHE THOUGHT WAS HER TASER
IN MINNESOTA. BEFORE FIRED
BEFORE FIRING SHIELD TASER
TASER. I DIDN'T KNOW THAT SHE
HAD FIRED A GUN UNTIL AFTER THE
FACT. WHAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
PREVENT FUTURE VICTIMS OF FATAL
GUNSHOT WOUNDS IT ALSO AIMS TO
AVOID THE EMOTIONAL MENTAL
DISTRESS TO THE OFFICER WHO
MISTAKENLY FIRED THEIR WEAPON.
STUDIES SHOW THAT OFFICERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO DIE BY SUICIDE.
THAN IN THE LINE OF DUTY THE
MOST OFFICERS NEVER SEEK MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. THIS BILL AS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE TO PREVENT
FATAL CATASTROPHES BY REQUIRING
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. TO
CARRY THEIR TASERS ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF THE PRIMARY
WEAPON. WITH THIS REQUIREMENT WE
AIM TO PREVENT FUTURE CALAMITIES
BY SETTING UP OFFICERS FOR
SUCCESS WHEN ENTERING THE HIGH
RISK SITUATION WHERE DECISIONS
ARE MADE IN A MOMENT. THIS BILLS
ENJOYED CONSENT STATUS THUS FAR
IN THE MOMENT I'M TAKING TODAY'S
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR
LACKEY WITHOUT OBJECTION WE I'M
SORRY. DR QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FORTINO SIX. I JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT MR LEE. DREW
HIS GUN WITH HIS RIGHT HAND HIS-
MATTHEW DIRT WITH HIS RIGHT HAND
BUT HE COULD ALSO DRAW THE
TEACHER WITH HIS RIGHT HAND HE
HAD ARRANGED THE TASER IN THE
WAY THAT HE COULD CROSS. SO BOB
COULD YOU PUT SOMETHING
EXPLICITLY IN THE BILL THAT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO BE DROPPED WITH YOUR
WEEKEND RATHER THAN REACH AROUND
WITH YOUR STRONG HAND- FOR THE
TASER. WHAT WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IS WE'VE CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE TO INDICATE THAT IT'S
ON A DIFFERENT SIDE OF THEIR
PRIMARY WEAPON THE PRIMARY
WEAPON IT NEEDS TO BE NOT
CONFUSED WITH THE SAME SIDE AND
THAT'S WE'VE DONE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE YUP BUT- IF YOU CAN
DRAW IT WITH YOUR STRONG HAND ON
YOUR WEAK SIDE. THERE'S THAT'S
WHAT MR LEE DID HE HAD HIS.
CHANGER ON IS IT WAS THE SAME
SORT OF HIS PRIMARY WEAPON. NO
MEMBERS MEMBERS WE DON'T ENGAGE
IN COLLOQUY ON THE FLOOR- DR
CORRECT IF YOU MIGHT DISCUSSES
WITH MR LACKEY. OF THE FOUR
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE AMENDMENT
ITSELF. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
. ON THIS AMENDMENT ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE I. SEVENTY AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINTED
BACK ON FILE. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB FIVE
FIFTY TWO BY MISS CORK SILVA FOR
THE PURPOSE OF MEMIKIRKAN READ
WITH THE METS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY TWO WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSUMING RECORDS SILVA. IT'S
QUICK SILVA ON THE MEMONS. THE
MORNING MIST SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIVE TWO WOULD ALLOW NOT REQUIRE
SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES TO ENTER
INTO THE INTEGRATED SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND ACCESS TO BE
FIT PAVE URAL AND MENTAL
SERVICES FOR ALL STUDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT. YOU MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. I BELIEVE MR HOLDEN HAS.
AMENDMENTS WE'RE GOING BACK TO
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDED CORKERY WITH A MESS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY SEVEN
WITH LIMITS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING. THE SURE HOLD ON THE-
OKAY YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT A SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENT TO AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
TO ADDRESS MEMBERS CONCERNS
REGARDING THE FAST COUNCIL'S
AUTHORITY THIS AMENDMENT REMOVES
THE FAST COUNCIL THE THIRD ISSUE
A SUBPOENA. I REMEMBER THIS
SECTION TO PRIORITIZE THE
COUNCIL'S PRIMARY GOAL OF CITY
STANDARDS THAT IMPROVE THE FAST
FOOD INDUSTRY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN
MISTER CLARK WHAT PURPOSE SIR WE
OBJECT TO THESE MOMENTS AFTER
RECALL THAT. MR FLOOR IS ASKING
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO
VOTE THESE ARE ON THE AMENDMENTS
. MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING IS
THE THRESHOLD ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE THIRTY
NINE KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINTED BACK ON FILE. AND MR
SANTIAGO. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN. FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN AB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF MEMORY WITH A MAN ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO MR SANTIAGO IN THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS ON THE DESK
WOULD ADDRESS OVER TECHNICAL
ISSUES RAISED BY THE BALLOT
DESIGN COMMITTEE AND ADD SEVERAL
CORNERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
. THIS FLORIDA. JUDGES MEMONS
LOCAL VOTE MISTER FLORES RICK. A
CALL VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THESE
ARE THE MOMENTS. TO AB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE MAJORITY PRESENT VOTING
IS THE- VOTE THRESHOLD. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE TALLY THAT ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. THAT BILLS
OUT TO PRINT. IN BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE. MOVING THROUGH
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
GOVERNOR'S VETOES. ITEM SHALL BE
CONTINUED RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
ON RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. MISTER REAVIS. TRY
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE AFTER WE
TAKE THAT OUT OF MOST. WE ARE
MOVING. TO ASSEMBLY THIRD. WHAT
A PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS FORTY
FIVE AND. FORTY SIX. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. AB FIVE
FIFTY ONE. BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO INDIVIDUAL
RETIREMENT PLANS OF MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THANK A MISPRINT BURST
AB FIVE FIVE ONE WOULD AUTHORIZE
CAL STIRS TO OFFER AND ACCEPT
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR TRADITIONAL
TAX DEFERRED IRA AND ROTH IRA
PLANS INCLUDING ROLLOVER FROM
ANY ELIGIBLE RETIREMENT PLANS
THE BILL WOULD AND NOT CAL
STIRRED RECEIVED CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM OUT OF OUR MEMBERS FORMER
ELIGIBLE MEMBERS WE HAVE. AND
THEIR SPOUSES. A PLAN. AB FIVE
FIVE ONE ENJOY THE SUPPORT OF
CUSTER'S CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ARE **** UP FOR A VOTE
. THANK YOU MR AT RISK OF SEEING
NO DISCUSSION. WE'RE DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
THAT AMOUNT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
THAT A VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL TITLEIST FORTY FOUR KNOWS
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES. WITH
THE SPECIFIED OF FORTY EIGHT
FIVE FORTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY. AB TWO
NINETY FIVE AYE MR JONES SAWYER
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER ACCOLADE IN THE
POPE PAUL SECONDARY EDUCATION
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWO NINETY FIVE WHICH
ESTABLISHES A WORKGROUP OF
HIGHER EDUCATION REPRESENTATIVES
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FREE COLLEGE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN CARRYING OUT THEIR
WORK THIS GROUP WILL FOCUS ON
DETERMINING WHICH CAMPUSES WOULD
BEST FIT. THE DEVELOP PROGRAM
MODEL IDENTIFYING IF THERE IS
ANY PARTICULAR STUDENT THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM
AND CREATING A MODEL THAT WILL
WORK IN TANDEM WITH THE EXISTING
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS. OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO PAT BROWN A
MASTER'S PROGRAM MASTERS PLAN ON
EDUCATION STUDENTS WERE NOT
CHARGE TUITION BECAUSE THE STATE
SOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT THERE WERE
AS FEW BARRIERS AS POSSIBLE TO A
MORE EDUCATED CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY. BY PROVIDING FREE
COLLEGE TO STUDENTS WE ARE WE
WERE CONSIDERED HE BEST
EDUCATED WORKFORCE IN THE NATION
COMPANIES CAME TO CALIFORNIA AND
WE FLOURISH. FOR MORE FOR MORE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES INCREASED
INVESTMENTS FURTHER IT IS MY
VISION AS A RESULT OF THIS
PROGRAM WILL HELP US IDENTIFY
WAYS TO EVALUATE COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE SUCH AS BY PROVIDING
MORE DOCTORS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS INCREASING MORE
SOCIAL. TO HELP ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS BY INVESTING IN OUR
STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
WE CAN HELP BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ASSIST OUR
COMMUNITIES RAISE OUR CHILDREN'S
ECONOMIC. AND RIGHT NOW. PARTNER. RESPECTFULLY DR. THANK FOR
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHERE ESERVER WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE. AB
THREE TWENTY ONE FIVE IS VALID
THERE'S- AND THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALAVERAS AND
OTHER SNACK LETTING THE CHILD
CARE MS VALIDATORS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB THREE TWO ONE
WHICH WILL HELP SOME OF OUR
STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN LOW INCOME DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR PRIORITY ENROLLMENT FOR
STATE CHILD CARE SERVICES. AND
PRESCHOOL. UNFORTUNATELY DAHLE
LANGUAGE TYPICALLY LAGGED BEHIND
THEIR NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKING
PEERS AADEMICALLY IF THEY
TRANSITION TO TAKE K. TWELVE
WITHOUT ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. BUT
MULTIPLE STUDIES SHOW THAT ONCE
DAHLE LANGUAGE LEARNERS BECOME
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH THEIR TEST
SCORES ACADEMIC OUTCOMES
DRASTICALLY IMPROVE. BY MAKING
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT FOR STATE CHILD CARE
SERVICES IN PRESCHOOL AB THREE
TWO ONE OFFERS ONE OF MEANINGFUL
WAY FOR STATE FOR THE STATE TO
HELP. LOW INCOME DAHLE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS BETTER REQUIRE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY BEFORE THEY
AND TATE ENTER TO K. THROUGH
TWELVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
VOTERS. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CORPORAL. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE. CALAVO
HIGHS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO. AB THREE NINETY
NINE. BY MISTER SALAS CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
MISTER CELIS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS I PERCENT SIMPLY BILL
THREE NINETY NINE IT'S A
REASONABLE APPROACH TO HELP
INJURED WORKERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
RECELL SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THIS ITEM. THE
CORPORAL. DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRABLE. THE CLARK WELLS
CULTURAL TELL YOU WHAT I FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
. IN FOLLOWER. FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE. AB FOUR OH EIGHT BY MISS
CORK SILVA. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS ARE NOT GOING TO HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND USE THIS QUICK
SILVA YOU MAY OPEN. REPORTED
THAT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ARE NOT IDENTIFYING AND
ADEQUATELY PROVIDING SERVICES TO
HOMELESS STUDENTS THOUGHT AUDIT
FOUND THAT SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
REPORTED ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND HOMELESS YOUTH
AND I QUOTE ONLY WHICH IS HUGE
WELL THEY BELIEVED AT LEAST
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN FACT OF THE E.
ELLIE AS THAT WERE REVIEWED IN
THE AUDIT NONE OF THEM FISH'S.
BRAINS THAT COULD HELP THEM
IDENTIFY YOUTH WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AB
FOUR OH FOUR EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
ALLEY A HOMELESS LIAISONS TO
OFFER TRAINING ON IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS YOUTH TO TEACHERS PARA
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER SCHOOL
STAFF WHO HAVE DAILY.
CONNECTIONS WITH STUDENTS THE
HOMELESS LIAISONS ARE PART OF
THAT OUT REACH SCHOOL TEACHERS
AND STAFF AND WILL ALSO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON SERVICES THE
LIAISONS PROVIDE AS WELL AS THE
REFERRAL PROCESS. NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALLEY
AS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND
HAVE AN ACCURATE COUNT OF THE
STUDENTS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
EARLY INTERVENTION AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THREE OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A JOIN
AUTHOR OF AB FOUR AWAY AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT BY HAVING OUR SCHOOLS
BECOME BETTER EQUIPPED TO
IDENTIFY AND HOUSE STUDENTS BY
OFFERING TRAINING TO THE SCHOOL
STAFF- WE WILL. FIND THE
RESOURCES TO MEET THE STUDENTS
NEEDS TO BECOME SUCCESSFUL AND
FUTURE LEADERS OF CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY. ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS. SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS SHOULD RESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY FOUR. AB FOUR FIFTY
TWO BY MISS FRIEDMAN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE SAFETY. MISS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I'M AN AVID A
NEWSPAPER READER I READ THE
NEWSPAPER AND MEDIA SOURCES
EVERY DAY I LAST WEEK I WAS
REALLY HORRIFIED TO READ YET
ANOTHER STORY. ABOUT A CHILD
KILLED BECAUSE SOMEONE IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLD ANOTHER YOUNGER CHILD
IN THIS CASE IT WAS A TODDLER
FOUND AN UNSECURED FIREARM IN
THE HOUSE. LAYING WITH IT. AND
THE RESULT WAS THAT A TWELVE
YEAR OLD GIRL WAS SHOT TO DEATH
. LAST YEAR IN AMERICA TWENTY
TWENTY. FIREARMS BECAME THE
NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN PREVIOUSLY HAD BEEN
AUTO ACCIDENTS BUT SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY NOW
SOME OF THESE WERE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THESE WERE
INTENTIONAL MURDERS BUT MOST OF
THEM. WERE UNINTENTIONAL OR
CHILDREN WHO FOUND AN UNSECURED
FIREARM IN A PARENT'S HOME. HE
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THAT OLDER
CHILD WHO KNEW HOW TO HANDLE A
GUN RESPONSIBLY WAS SUICIDAL.
THESE ARE TRAGEDIES THAT ARE
COMPLETELY AVOIDABLE. IF A
PARENT SECURELY LOCKS THEIR GUN
AS REQUIRED BY LAW IN CALIFORNIA
. MOST OF THESE ACCIDENTS COULD
BE PREVENTED. AB FOUR FIFTY TWO
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT OUR SCHOOLS
WHEN THEY DO THEIR NORMAL
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION TO PARENTS
ABOUT A NUMBER OF ISSUES ALSO
NOTIFY PARENTS ABOUT THE LAWS
REGARDING SAFE STORAGE OF
FIREARMS AND REMIND THEM OF THE
REASONS THAT PUTTING A GUN IN A
SHOE BOX IN THE TOP OF THE
CLOSET OR KEEPING IT IN A DRAWER
OR NOT WALKING A GUN CASE.
COMPLETELY ON A DOUBLE INTEREST
FOR THEM AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
IN THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANKS FRIEDMAN IS BACKING HIM
YOUR RANGE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR FIFTY TWO AND WANT TO
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM.
GLENDALE FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. AS THAT A MOM
I FOUND OUT. THAT OTHERS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD DID HAVE GUNS THAT
WERE NOT SAFELY STORED AND I
STARTED ASKING THE QUESTION WHEN
MY KIDS ARE GONE. BATES WELL
SOMETIMES. WITH A HIGH I'M YOU
HAVE GUNS IN YOUR HOME AND IF SO
HOW ARE THEY STORED. AND I WAS
SURPRISED BY HOW MANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT. I CHILDREN
SOCIALIZE WITH HAD THE GUNS THAT
WERE NOT STORED SAFELY OFTEN
WHEN THEY STARTED THE
CONVERSATION THE PARENT WOULD
REALIZE. MAYBE THERE IS A BETTER
WAY TO DO IT AND THEY WOULD
CHOOSE TO GET A GUN LOCK OR A
GUN SAFE AND THEN I WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE MY CHILD GOING AND
PLAYING IN THAT HOME. BUT THE
CONVERSATION WAS SIMPLE ENOUGH
TO CHANGE THE WAY PEOPLE
OPERATED AND THAT IS WHY WHEN IT
THANK YOU. M. OUR COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL BECAUSE
EDUCATION IS SO CRITICAL IT WILL
SAVE LIVES IT IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE YET IT IS ONE THAT WILL
IMPACT MANY FAMILIES AND
HOPEFULLY CHANGE. THE COURSE OF
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES THANK YOU
. THANK RESPECT QUE HAN. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. OR CALL THE ROLL.
THAT ABOUT OUR MEMBERS VOTERS
ADEBAYO. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE FIFTY UP AS SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY TWO BY MR
FONG SACRAMENTO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AND ACTIVATING THE
FORESTRY. MISTER FOX. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. WILDFIRES
HAVE DEVASTATED HOMES AND ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES AND SADLY LIVES HAVE
BEEN LOST REDUCING FUELS
IMPROPERLY MANAGING FORCE LANDS
ARE PROVEN METHODS OF PREVENTING
FUTURE FIRES WITHOUT THE HELP OF
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS THE STATE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE
FORCE HEALTH AND WELFARE
RESILIENT. THIS IS CRITICAL OF
THE STATE IS GOING TO MEET ITS
ANNUAL GOAL OF TREATING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES BEFORE
HARVESTING TIMBER ON PRIVATE
LAND LAND OWNERS MADE A TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN TO PROCEED WITH
FUELS MANAGEMENT WITH ADDED
REQUIREMENTS HOWEVER LANDOWNERS
MAY OBTAIN A STREAMLINED PROCESS
IF THE TIMBER HARVESTS REDUCES
THE RATE. DURATION FIRE
IGNITABILITY AND INTENSITY A
FIRE SPREAD THE CURRENT FORCE
FIRE PREVENTION PILOT PROJECT
EXEMPTION HAS ENABLED PRIVATE
FOREST LANDOWNERS TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE STATE'S MISSION OF
PREVENTING FUTURE OURS AND
DAMPENING THEIR INTENSITY
WITHOUT THE EXTENSION OF THIS
PROGRAM FOREST RISK TO. FILL THE
IN TREES AND BRUSH BY EXTENDING
THE SONS DATE OF THE PILOT. AB
FIVE TWO TWO ONE POWER
LANDOWNERS TO SUSTAINABLY
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
HEALTHY FORCE MANAGEMENT AND
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE IS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE GOAL OF
TREATED LAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
FONG SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CORPORAL. THERE ARE
SEVERAL MEMBERS VOTERS ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTING THEM.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF OUR ICE
FIFTY KNOWS THREE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS. WE PASS
TEMPORARILY. COMMISSION IS ERIN
IS READY WE WILL TAKE UP FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX. AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT BYE MISTER NAZARIAN
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE SYRIAN AND OTHERS BACK
LIVING SCHOOL MEALS MICHIZANE
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENTS
AND GRANT MONEY TO SCHOOLS TO
INCENTIVIZE THE ADOPTION OF
PLANT BASED VEGETARIAN AND
RESTRICTED DIET MEALS AND PLANT
BASED MILK OPTIONS. ALSO IT WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON HOW TO SERVE
ELIGIBLE YOUNGER SIBLINGS A
FEDERALLY REIMBURSABLE MEAL AT A
SCHOOL SITE THAT THEIR SIBLING
ATTENDS. WE'VE TAKEN SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND OUR BILL TO
INCLUDE TWO OTHER DIET OPTIONS
FOR REIMBURSEMENT AND GRANT
MONEY RESTRICTED DIET FOOD
OPTION WHICH INCLUDES BUT IS NOT
LIMITED TO RELIGIOUS DIETARY
RESTRICTIONS ANY VEGETARIAN FOOD
OPTION. LAST YEAR WE TOOK THE
FIRST STEP TOWARD RESPONDING TO
CHILD CHILDHOOD HUNGER BY
PASSING THE UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEAL PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET NOW
IT'S TIME FOR US TO DISCUSS HOW
WE FEED OUR NON SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. AND WHAT FOODS WE ARE
FEEDING OUR CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS
AND BE MINDFUL OF THE MANY
DIETARY RESTRICTIONS AND
LIFESTYLES THAT EXIST AMONG THEM
. AS HAVE SEEN FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THEIR STUDENTS. AND THIS BILL
CAN DO THAT FOR MANY OF THEM.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW TO YOU
COLLEAGUES TO THAT THIS BILL HAS
BEEN EXPANDED FROM SOLELY PLANT
BASED FOODS TO INCLUDE DIETARY
AND MEAT. I'M SORRY DAIRY AND
MEAT. AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL DIETS WHETHER
PLANT BASED VEGETARIAN HALAL
KOSHER GLUTEN FREE YOU NAME IT.
THE BILL PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT
OF UP TO TWENTY CENTS FOR EACH
PLANT BASED FOOD OPTION.
RESTRICTED DIET OPTION AND
VEGETARIAN OPTION AND TEN CENTS
FOR A PLANT BASED MILK OPTION.
LET ME REITERATE THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDES MEAT AND DAIRY AS WELL
. AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT ALSO
ROVIDES A GRANT OF UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
TRAINING RESOURCES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
AND COMPENSATION FOR ADDITIONAL
WORK ADDED AND A ONE TIME GRANT
OF THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HELP
COLLECT NECESSARY DATA.
FURTHERMORE IT REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ISSUE INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN FEED
THE YOUNGER SIBLINGS OF SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN A FREE BREAKFAST OR
MORNING SNACKS. GUARANTEEING
THAT THEY ARE FED THE MOST
IMPORTANT MEAL OF THE DAY WE'VE
MET WITH OPPOSITION AND I'VE
HEARD THEIR CONCERNS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT WE MEET
THEIR NEEDS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MRS AREA. MS RIVAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A JOIN
AUTHOR OF AB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
LED THE NATION BY CREATING A
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM
THAT WILL PROVIDE TWO FREE MEALS
TO EVERY K. TWELVE STUDENT IN
THE STATE. AB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
SUPPLEMENTS THIS PROGRAM BY
ENSURING THAT SCHOOL MEALS ARE
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE SO THAT NO
STUDENT WITH DIETARY
RESTRICTIONS WILL GO HUNGRY
WHILE LEARNING AT SCHOOL. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH SCORE SILVA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS I ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT SCHOOL MEALS AND CHILD
NUTRITION ACT. MEMBERS MANY OF
US HAVE SEEN AN EXPLOSION IN
PLANT BASED MEALS MANY OF US
AREN'T SURE WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANS BUT WHAT IT DOES MEAN FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IS THAT THEY
WILL HAVE A CHOICE NOT A MANDATE
AGAIN THESE ARE GRANT PROGRAMS
BUT WHAT IT MEANS FOR OUR
GROWING LATINO STUDENT
POPULATION. IS BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES SOME OF YOU MAY NOT
KNOW WHEN OUR LATINO COMMUNITIES
THAT OBESITY AND DIABETES ARE
SOME OF THE GROWING HEALTH
INDICATORS THAT YOUNG STUDENTS
ARE ATTAINING NOW AS EARLY AS IN
THEIR TEENS FIFTEEN YEAR OLD.
PLANT BASED MEALS HAVE SHOWN ONE
TO BRING DOWN MANY MANY POOR
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS AGAIN IT IS NOT A
MANDATE IT IS A GRANT PROGRAM
THIS WILL COMPLEMENT OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE GOING BACK
TO GUESS WHAT. COOKING WE KNOW
THAT MUCH OF OUR PROCESSED FOOD
ARE ALSO CREATING POOR OUTCOMES
AND SOME OF US AS OLD AS ME
REMEMBER WHEN WE ACTUALLY COOKED
IN OUR KITCHENS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. SO I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK WHICH COURSE OF MISSED
COOPER YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER LET ME BE CLEAR I
FULLY SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACCOMMODATING STUDENTS
NUTRITIONAL NEEDS THE HEALTH
RELIGIOUS OR PURPOSES. HOWEVER
AFTER CONCERNS. BECAUSE NOTHING
THE BILL I'VE READ. MANDATE THAT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT BY THE
PRODUCTS FROM CALIFORNIA-
CALIFORNIA'S A FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR AG INDUSTRY I WILL ASK MY
DISTRICT. IN A NUMBER OF YEARS
BACK IN THIS LEGISLATURE WE
PASSED A BILL THAT MANDATED THAT
SCHOOLS BY THEIR FRUIT CUPS
FROM. CALIFORNIA VENDORS IF
THEY'RE BUYING IT FROM FOLKS
FROM CHINA FROM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY SO. THAT IS THE QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR JUST TO MAKE SURE
IN THE BILL THAT MANDATED BY
FROM CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE BIG
ISSUES THINK ABOUT PRICES FOOD
PRICES- A LOST COVERAGE THEY'RE
GOING TO MEXICO. WE A LOT OF
GREAT THEY'RE GOING TO SOUTH
AMERICA A LOT OF CITRUS IN CHINA
SO WHEN YOU'RE CALIFORNIA FARMER
RANCHER. AND YOU'RE COMPETING
WITH A GLBAL MARKET IT'S TOUGH
BECAUSE THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THE PAST THREE
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S REALLY A
BIG ISSUE WITH THAT. AND YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT
HOPEFULLY OFFER CAN ANSWER IT IS
CLOSE. BUT IT IT REALLY COMES
WITH WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
FOR A FOOD MARKET WHERE FOR
INSTANCE- CARMEL BENNETT TRACTOR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH THAT
CHARGE CAN. USE ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE COUNTRY IN THE WORLD. HOW
ARE FARMERS FOR TO COMPETE
BECAUSE THIS THIS ONE ARE TIED
BEHIND THEIR BACKS. CAL DOES.
GOOD JOB OUT OF A SLUMP. IT
IMPACT THAT WILL GIVE YOU
ANOTHER TO- A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO ONE OF MY SENATE COLLEAGUES
HAD A BILL. ON THE DAIRY ISSUE
TO BASICALLY DO AWAY WITH
CALLAS. WE PASSED A BILL THAT
HAS THE LOWEST ANTIBIOTICS
DINNERS IN THE COUNTRY THE
LOWEST. AND WE'RE ON THE VERGE
BEFORE A FEW YEARS BACK THE
FORCING OUR DAIRY HERDS. OUT OF
CALIFORNIANS BEING BROUGHT IN
FROM ELSEWHERE SO YOU KNOW WE
LOSE CONTROL OF THAT SO. MY
CONCERN IS HOW DO WE DO THAT ONE
IN SEVEN KIDS IN CALIFORNIA- FOR
FOOD INSECURE. THEY HAVE THAT
RIGHT NOW SO IF YOU OFFER CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AND I JUST
AT THE END OF THE DAY- IT'S A
MATTER OF EQUITY AND I SEE A LOT
OF SCHOOLS THAT ARE MORE. WELL
OFF. TAKING ADVANTAGE THIS
PROGRAM EVEN THOSE GRANT FUNDED.
THAN OUR SCHOOLS IN THESE
MINORITY AREAS SO IF YOU OFFICE. THAT APPRECIATE THAT. MISTER
JERRY MAN THAT A IS CLOSE. TO
WHEN YOU ORDER. YOUR RIGHT. YES
I THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FOR THE FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR TAKING ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. OF
HEALTHY SCHOOL LUNCHES. MY
CONCERNS ARE SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE- WE
CLEARLY SHARE THE SAME GOALS.
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. OF HAVING
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTHY.
AND SUSTAINABLE MEALS THIS
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR THE
BIDEN HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
HAVE BEEN CHAMPING A FARM TO
SCHOOL CONCEPT THE PRIORITIZE
FRESH AND LOCALLY SOURCED FOOD
ITEMS. MY CONCERN IS THAT- THIS
BILL COULD INCENTIVIZE. OF PLANT
BASED FOODS. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ORIGIN OVER LOCALLY SOURCED FOOD
SO. I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
BUT I HOPE THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS. WE'VE GOT A-
MAZING LOCALLY SOURCE FOODS IN
IN IN MANY OF THE EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT. AND I
WOULD HATE THIS SOMEHOW
DISINCENTIVE EYES THAT. WERE IN
FAVOR SOMETHING BY COME FROM
ANOTHER STATE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD DOCTOR FOR. CORPORATE IS
MIKE DOWN MISTER MURATSUCHI ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE BUT- AS A PARENT
AND AS A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AUTHOR IS AWARE THAT MY
EXPERIENCE I HAVE NO DATA TO
SUPPORT IT BUT MY EXPERIENCE IS
THAT AS MUCH AS WE TRY TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY EATING. WHEN YOU
GO TO THE OUR SCHOOLS AND YOU
SEE YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN THE WASTE
BASKETS YOU SEE ALL THE HEALTHY
FOOD THAT'S BEING THROWN YOU
KNOW THE APPLES IN THE SALADS
ARE THROWN AWAY IN THE AND THE
AND THE GARBAGE CANS THEY THE
PIZZA SENATE ORDERS YOU KNOW IT
THE FRUSTRATES ME AS MUCH AS
ANYONE BUT- I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE- TRY TO PROMOTE
YOU KNOW OPTIONS ARE TRYING TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY EATING. THAT SO
WE TRY TO WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO THE
LANDFILL WITH MORE WASTED FOOD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI. DR WORK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER UP
MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS BILL
SEEMS TO GIVE A PREFERENCE TO
PLANT BASED MILK SUBSTITUTES
OVER MAIL AND AT LEAST FOR MANY
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE IT'S REALLY
PREFERABLE TO HAVE- JERRY MAIL
AS OPPOSED TO PLANT BASED MILK
AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
YOUR BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR QUIRK MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER RISES JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AND- ON A COUPLE OF
THE POINTS OR RAISES ALL OF
EVERYONE RAISING SOME PRETTY
VALID CONCERNS HOWEVER. ON SOME
OF THEM FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
SOURCING OF FOOD I DON'T BELIEVE
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A REQUIREMENT
THE FOOD COMING INTO OUR SCHOOLS
OUR SOURCE IN CALIFORNIA IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO WRITE A BILL
BILL ON THAT IN GENERAL THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN HAVE A MORE IN
DEPTH CONVERSATION ABOUT I THINK
THE SCHOOLS WITH. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD RAISE SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING COSTING ON
THAT BUT I THINK IT'S A VERY
FAIR ARGUMENT OR ER DISCUSSION
TO HAVE SEPARATE FROM THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE WE DON'T
DO IT ANYWAY WE DON'T REQUIRE
HAVE THAT REQUIREMENT. FOR OUR
FOOD SUPPLY RIGHT NOW COMING
INTO OUR SCHOOLS WIDELY WE
CREATE THAT REQUIREMENT FOR THIS
ONE PARTICULAR GRANT PROGRAM
WITH IT WHICH AGAIN IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
CHOOSE TO OPT IN. SECONDLY IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE STARTED A
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO TO HAVE
A SALAD BARS WE STARTED OUR
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
BUT WE FOUND- NOT ANECDOTALLY
BUT THE RESEARCH SHOWED IS THAT
THE KIDS ACTUALLY THE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY DID GRAVITATE TOWARDS
THE SOUTH WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE A
PARENT LOOKING OVER THEIR
SHOULDER. AND THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
THE OPTIONS THAT IT ACTUALLY
BECOMES A MEANINGFUL OPT FOR
THEM BUT THEY DO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE DON'T HAVE PIZZA EVERY
DAY- BUT WHAT THEY DO WHAT DO
YOU DO FIND IS THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF PEER PRESSURE INVOLVED
THEY SEE OTHER FRIENDS AND FOLKS
IN THE SALADS. THEY START DOING
IT TOO SO I THINK IT GOES BOTH
WAYS IN THAT REGARD OTHERS YOU
KNOW IT BUT ALWAYS I THINK THE
ISSUE OF WHO WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE
OF CONCERN INCLUDING OUR SCHOOLS
BUT THAT'S ONE THING WE FOUND IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. THE REGARD
FOR THE PLANT BASED MILKS IT'S
ABOUT CREATING NEW OPTIONS OF
RIGHT NOW OF MILK OF DAIRY MILK
IS ALREADY PROVIDED SO IT'S
ABOUT PROVIDING MORE OPTIONS NOT
FORCING ONE TYPE OF NUMBER
SAYING HERE'S VARIETY OPTIONS I
HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS. THAT ARE
LACTOSE INTOLERANT OR ALLERGIC
TO DAIRY AND THEN THEY DON'T GET
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE TO HAVE
NO. THEIR SCHOOL DAY SO THESE
ARE ALL ISSUES AND QUESTION OR
OR VALID BUT I THINK THAT THIS
PUT PROGRAM BEING IN THE PROGRAM
ALLOWS OPERA FOR A TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE KIND OF FOOD
THAT'S COMING IN TO OUR SCHOOLS
ALLOW DISTRICTS TO APPLY FR
GRANTS TO TRY ONE OF PROGRAMS
THAT CAN HELP EDUCATE US EVEN
MORE AND ADDITIONALLY I ALSO
AGREE WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS
ANY OPPORTUNITY THERE IS FOR US
TO INCENTIVIZE YOU KNOW PEOPLE
SOURCING FROM LOCAL FARMS WHAT
HAVE YOU THAT COULD BE PART OF A
DISTRICT GRANT. BUT THEY PUT IS
ABLE TO WORK WITH A LOCAL
FARMERS AND SO ON SO THE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT WAS SET UP TO THAT
CAN'T BE EITHER ADDRESS OR
WORKED ON GOING FORWARD WITH
THIS PROGRAM IN ITSELF ALLOWS US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION REGARDING SCHOOL
NUTRITION- I WILL RESPECT THE
ANSWER I DON'T THINK YOU. THANK
YU MISTER KALRA MISS PARA QUE
HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANTED
TO TOUCH ON ONE THING WHICH IS
THAT WE AS A BODY CONSTANTLY
TALK ABOUT MAKING CALIFORNIA
ORE INCLUSIVE. AND EQUITABLE.
MY SISTER LIVES IN A STATE THAT
HAS- FREE. ACCESS TO FOOD FOR
ALL STUDENTS AND I MY NIECES
FIRST DAY OF TKC CAME HOME WITH
HER LEFTOVER BREAKFAST. WHICH
WAS A BACON OMELET. MY SISTER
HAS A KOSHER HOUSEHOLD. AND MY
NIECE HAD NEVER HAD BACON IN HER
LIFE NOR DID HER RELIGION PERMIT
HER TO DO SO. AND IT'S CRITICAL
THAT EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA
CHILD IS ABLE TO EXPRESS THEIR
RELIGION AND HAVE ACCESS TO
FOODS IN THEIR SCHOOL. THAT
MEETS THOSE NEEDS AND SO WE MUST
DO. TAKE ACTIONS LIKE THIS TO
EXPAND OUR OPTIONS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF EVERY. KID IN
CALIFORNIA WHO NEEDS KOSHER AND
HALAL MEALS THEY'RE IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THEM INTO CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU IS PARA QUE HAVE SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MISTER AND MISS
HEARING YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TRY TO JOT DOWN
THE NOTES AS BEST AS I COULD SO.
FIRST OF ALL- TO MY COLLEAGUES
FROM ORANGE COUNTY SAN JOSE. SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND ORINDA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF WORDS- AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES FROM HAYWARD
CLARKSBURG. TORRANCE IN
SACRAMENTO. LET LET ME GIVE YOU
BRIEF RESPONSES TO EACH OF YOUR
CONCERNS. FOLKS ESPECIALLY TO MY
COLLEAGUES FROM HAYWARD AND
CLARKSBURG THE INCENTIVE IS PUT
INTO PLACE TO PROMOTE. AN OPTION
. HOW YOU CHANGE A CULTURE IS BY
FIRST NOT JUST LEGISLATING AND
WE TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME.
YOU DN'T JUST COME DOWN HARD
WHAT YOU INSTEAD DO IS
INCENTIVIZE THE CERTAIN WAY OF
THINKING TO SEE IF IT CATCHES ON
OR NOT THAT'S ALL THIS IS. THESE
OPTIONS HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN TO
US. WHEN WE WERE STUDENTS. BUT
WE MAY HAVE HAD THE BENEFIT OF
IT AT HOME. AND AS YOU GET OLDER
AND YOU REALIZE WHAT'S GOING ON
IN SOCIETY AND THAT THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE MANY STUDENTS. FROM
WHERE YOU LIVE DOWN THE BLOCK
FROM WHERE YOU LIVE WHO RELY ON
THE DAY OLD HOT DOG THAT'S- YOU
KNOW ROLLING SLOWLY OVER AT A
LOCAL CONVENIENCE STORE. YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT V. THOSE
CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY HAVE A
BETTER OPTION. OF TO THEIR
SCHOOLS AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
OTHER THINGS THERE ARE THAT THEY
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SO IN
ORDER. IN ORDER TO. CHANGE THE
MINDSET OR AT LEAST ALLOW AN
OPTION YOU INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS. SO IF WE DON'T EVEN
WANNA MOVE THEN WE DON'T EVEN
CHANGE THINGS BY INCENTIVIZING
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS SAYING DON'T EVEN
DARE TO CHANGE THE STATUS QUO.
BY THE WAY. THE OPPOSITION FOR
THIS BILL WAS NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL TWO YEARS AGO-
UNFORTUNATELY THEY'VE CHOSEN TO.
GO BACK TO OPPOSITION AND I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUALLY WORKING
WITH THEM BUT I HAVE NOT YET
HEARD EXACTLY THE REASON WHY.
THEY WANT TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
EXCEPT FOR COMPLETELY TAKING OUT
ONE SECTION OF THE BILL. AND TO
ME THAT'S THE OPTION PORTION OF
THE BILL. SO IT'S CRITICAL FOR
US TO PROVIDE THESE OPTIONS
SECOND OF- TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM
TORRANCE WHO TALKED ABOUT-
THROWING AWAY MEALS I KNOW I
WORRY ABOUT THAT MYSELF QUITE A
BIT. BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM
THAT'S NOT SEEN AS WELL IN MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FILLED AND ALSO
DON'T HAVE THE OPTION TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE IN LARGER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE IN LOS
ANGELES WHERE I WAS MOTIVATED TO
DO THIS BILL. THE DEPENDED FOR
THIS BILL FORD WAS BECAUSE OF
THE ALLEYS BEST PROGRAM. IF ANY
OF YOU HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
AND I KNOW MANY OF YOU FROM LA
HAVE VISITED LA'S BEST PROGRAM.
YOU'LL SEE THE POOREST OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOLS. STAY
AFTER SCHOOL AND LEARN ABOUT
NUTRITION LEARN ABOUT COOKING
ELEMENTARY KIDS LEARNING ABOUT
COOKING AND LEARNING WHAT SPORTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN SO THAT THEY
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE WAY OF
BECOMING HEALTHIER. THERE ARE
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS THAT DO THIS
BUT THEY ALSO NEED THE SUPPORT
OF US TO PROVIDE FURTHER
INCENTIVES TO THEM AND THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL DOES IT BUILDS IN
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM- SO. I
BELIEVE I ALSO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO BYE BYE PLACES BY
SPEAKING TO ALL OF THESE THREE
POINTS. ALEX DOT THIS BILL HAS A
HAS IS JUST PUT PUTTING INTO
PLACE AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM. AND
IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE WAY WE
LOOK AT THINGS AND APPROACH
THINGS WE NEED TO FIRST
INCENTIVIZE AN APPROACH AND SEE
IF IT WORKS. UP I RESPECTFULLY
AND HUMBLY ASK VERY AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MRS AREA
WITH THAT. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ACTIVO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO
DECIDE ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET ICE FORTY TWO NO SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN
A FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT. AB SIX SEVENTY
SIX BY MR HOLDEN. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
IMMACULATE FRANCHISES MR HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB SIX SEVENTY
SIX IS A BILL THAT WILL TAKE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO RECTIFY THE
ON BALANCE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FRANCHISEES FRANCHISOR. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN I AUTHORED AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE MAKING
CALIFORNIA THE STANDARD BEARER
OF FAIRNESS FOR THE FRANCHISE OR
IN FRANCHISEE RELATIONSHIP.
BECAUSE OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS
A FRANCHISEE IN THE STORIES I
HEARD FROM CURRENT FRANCHISEES.
AND WHILE IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TWENTY TWENTY IS SHOWN AS
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE. TO BRING FAIRNESS TO THE
SYSTEM. BETWEEN ABDICATING
RESPONSIBILITY FRANCHISEES
DURING THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE REVELATION OF
UNFAIR TREATMENT OF FRANCHISEES
OF COLOR. TIME HAS REVEALED THAT
MORE ISSUES NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
. THIS BILL DOES MULTIPLE THINGS
TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES THAT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS FRANCHISE
ORES FROM INFLUENCING WERE
FRANCHISEE CAN PURCHASE A
FRANCHISE BASED ON A PROTECTED
CLASS SUCH AS RACE. WHICH HAS
BEEN THE SUBJECT OF ON GOING
LAWSUITS AGAINST MCDONALD'S BY
AFRICAN AMERICAN FRANCHISEES.
PREVENTS FRANCHISE ORDERS FROM
TRANSFERRING ALL LIABILITY
BURDEN ONTO FRANCHISEES IN
EXCHANGE FOR FINANCIAL HELP
DURING THE STATE EMERGENCY. THIS
BILL CREATES A MORE FAIR PROCESS
WERE PARTIES. HAVE A STATE TO
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT
FRANCHISEES- WHEN AN AGREEMENT
IS BEING TERMINATED. ALLOWS OF
TRANSFER BUYER OF A FRANCHISE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO RECEIVE THE
PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED IN AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. I WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE AND
HAVE VERY RECENT POSITIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
CONCERNED PARTIES ON THESE
PROVISIONS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CLARK WILL OF THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX. NO ZERO SEVEN PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE AB SIX
EIGHTY TWO BY MR BLOOM CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING THIS ALONE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB SIX
EIGHTY TO A MEASURE TO
INCENTIVIZE CO HOUSING CO
HOUSING ALSO KNOWN AS COMMUNAL
LIVING IS TYPICALLY MADE UP OF
UNITS THAT ARE SMALLER THAN FOUR
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET. BUT OFFERED
SHARED KITCHEN AND DINING AREAS
AND IS MORE AFFORDABLE THAN THE
AVERAGE STUDIO OR ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT. THESE NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE
IDEAL FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
BUT CANNOT COMPETE FOR MARKET
RATE APARTMENTS. WE CALL THAT
THE MISSING MIDDLE. COHOUSING
MODEL CAN ALSO BENEFIT SENIORS
PROVIDING SENIORS BOTH PRIVACY
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT. AB SIXTY
TWO WILL ALLOW CO HOUSING TO
QUALIFY FOR INCENTIVES UNDER THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW AND HELP
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
WITHIN ALREADY COSTLY PARCEL OF
LAND. EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO WILL
HELP DIVERSIFY THE HOUSING STOCK
AND ENCOURAGE MORE NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK YOU JUST ONE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DERRIFORD ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROADSIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX NO
SEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSER TERRAFORM SIXTY WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH CLOUT OF SIXTY
ONE. FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO IS MR
O'DONNELL'S AB NINE OH TWO
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALONG AND
ACCORDING TO SCHOOL FACILITIES.
SURE O'DONNELL YOU MAIL BUT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB NINE OH TO ESTABLISH AS AN
ALTERNATIVE DESIGN BUILD PILOT
PROJECT FOR AWARDING SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS. THE
TRADITIONAL METHOD FOR AWARDING
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS IS DESIGN
BID BUILD WHERE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FIRST HIRES AN ARCHITECT TO
DESIGN A SCHOOL THEN GOES OUT TO
BID FOR CONSTRUCTION. UNDER
DESIGN BUILD A SCHOOL DISTRICT
SEEKS BIDS FOR BOTH THE DESIGN
AND THE CONSTRUCTION EIGHTY NINE
OH TWO ALLOWS A LIMITED NUMBER
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO AWARD AN
INITIAL BID THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE CONSTRUCTION COSTS
AND INSTEAD ALLOWS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO RENEGOTIATE WITH THE
DESIGN BUILD TEAM ONCE THERE'S A
DESIGN. THIS WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE PRICES SCHOOL DISTRICT
PAYS IS MORE IN LINE WITH THE
TRUE COST OF CONSTRUCTION LAST
YEAR THROUGH A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES RECEIVED
AUTHORITY TO USE PROGRESSIVE
DESIGN BUILD THAT IS VERY
SIMILAR THIS BILL AGAIN
ESTABLISHES A SIMILAR PROCESS
FOR DISTRICTS WITH FIFTY
THOUSAND OR MORE ADA ABOUT
ELEVEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DONNA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE
ITEM OR CALL THE ROLL.
SACRAMENTO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. FOR TWELVE.
CLOSE RUSSIA THAILAND I FIFTY
TWO KNOWS FIVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY FOUR. MR TANG'S AB. TEN
SIXTY SEVEN. AND THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY A SLIMMER FITTING AND
ACTUALLY THE BETTER CONTAINERS
MISTER TECH THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER THIRTY YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA PASSED LANDMARK
LEGISLATION REGARDING THE
RECYCLING OF BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THAT TIME
PERIOD WE'VE SEEN RECYCLING
CENTERS CLOSE WE'VE ALSO SEEN
DIFFICULTY WITH CONSUMERS BEING
ABLE TO REDEEM THEIR DEPOSITS.
AB TEN SIX SEVEN REQUIRES HELP
RECYCLE TO CONDUCT A STUDY TO
MEASURE HOW THE EFFECTIVE IN
LIEU FEE PROVISION IN ENSURING
THAT THEIR OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO REDEEM THEIR
DEPOSITS IT ALSO CONSIDERING THE
FLAT FEE THAT RETAILERS HAVE TO
PAY A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY
WITHOUT SHOULD BE ADJUSTED
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US FOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU MICHELLE SENIOR
DISCUSSION. ON THE ITEM-
CORPORAL. SACRAMENTO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
ROOSEVELT. CLICK WELL. THE CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE MAYBE TEN NINETY THREE. BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER CORKERY.
SPEAKING CORKERY CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY THREE
BY SOME MEMBER JONES SAWYER
ACTUALLY THE NOTARIES PUBLIC
MISTER. MR DAILY PLEASE GIVE US
JONES. MISTRUST OR EMAIL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA NOTRE
PROTECTION ACT WHICH EXPANDS
ACCESS TO NOTARY SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA REP RESIDENTS
AUTHORIZING REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION ALSO KNOWN AS RON
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE STATE.
AB TEN NINETY THREE ALLOWS A
NOTARY PUBLIC TO REGISTER WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
PROVIDE ONLINE NOTED NOTED
NOTARIZATION CLARIFIED THEY MUST
QUALIFY AS A TRADITIONAL NOTARY
UNDER EXISTING LAW IT ALSO
REQUIRED TO SECTOR STATE TO
ADOPT RULES NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE ACT AND SPECIFIES
THIS RULE MAKING PROCESS MUST
ADDRESS ISSUES SUCH AS
ELECTRONIC JOURNALS RETENTION
AND- STORAGE OF RECORDS SECURITY
AND FEES. THAT MAY BE CHARGED BY
AN ONLINE THE REPUBLIC AND
ONLINE DELIVERY PLATFORM MOST
IMPORTANTLY INSURANCE
COLLABORATION BY REPLYING TO
SECRETARY OF STATE TO CONSIDER
THE VIEWS OF STATE ENTITIES
DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES AND THE
PUBLIC IN DEVELOPING THE RULES
CALIFORNIA NOTARIES SERVE AS A
VITAL COMPONENT OF EVERYDAY LIFE
AND PERFORM INVALUABLE SERVICES
FOR BUSINESS LEGAL FINANCIAL AND
REAL ESTATE COMMUNITY. THIS
ONGOING CRISIS HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED FOR MORE CONVENIENT
ALTERNATIVE FOR THEIR ACCESS THE
NOTARY SERVICES AND NOTRE
CONSEILS MY MOTHER WHO'S BEEN IN
THE HOSPITAL NEEDED A NOTARY BUT
BECAUSE OF CLOVE IT ENDED
DRACONIAN. RULES THAT WE PUT
INTO ONLY ONE PERSON COULD VISIT
THE HOSPITAL WE COULDN'T
PROVIDER THOSE NOTARY SERVICES I
WISH WE HAD HAD ONLINE FOR THAT
REASON LAST YEAR INTRODUCED AB
TEN NINETY THREE AS A WAY TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO AND PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR NO
RESISTANT FOR CALIFORNIA. THIS
EFFORT HAS REQUIRED A GREAT DEAL
OF DISCUSSION AND COLLABORATION
TO ADDRESS VARIOUS PRIVACY AND
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY. IS A PRODUCT
OF A MONTHS LONG STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND IS WERE NOT OVER I
AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED INCLUDING THE ISSUE. OF
OUT OF STATE ONLINE NOTARIES
TEIXEIRA. FACT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WITH MY OFFICE. AND IN
AN ARC. AGENCIES ARE SET TO
RESUME AS SOON AS NEXT WEEK
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MICHELLE FOR SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SAID ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS WELL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT I FIFTY ONE
KNOWS FOR. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AB
ELEVEN TWENTY BY MR WHEN CLERK
WILL READ SOME OF YOUR ELEVEN
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
AN ACT RELATING TO CLINICAL
LABORATORIES MEASUREMENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN TWENTY WOULD ALLOW HEALTH
FACILITIES IN HOSPITALS TO
AUTHORIZE THE USE. OF NEW BLOOD
COLLECTION METHODS AND DEVICES
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT REQUIRES PHLEBOTOMIST TO
USE NEEDLES THE DROP BLOOD EVEN
THOUGH NEW NEEDLELESS COLLECTION
METHODS EXIST. CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS DESERVE GREATER ACCESS
TO NEW MEDICAL PRACTICES THAT
ARE SAFE. AND MORE COMFORTABLE
AND I JUST WANNA TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS REALLY PERSONAL TO ME
AND A LOT OF YOU HAVE TOLD ME
SIMILAR STORIES THIS FALL. MY
DAUGHTER IN LAW WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR TWO AND A HALF
WEEKS AND SHE HAD AN IV LAW. BUT
BECAUSE THE NURSES WERE SO BUSY
AT THAT HOSPITAL THE
PHLEBOTOMIST HAD TO DRAW THE
BLOOD TWICE TODAY. AND BY THE
END OF THAT TWO AND A HALF WEEKS
SHE HAD HAD SO MANY POSTS THAT
ARE ARMS WERE BOTH ARMSWERE
COMPLETELY BLACK AND BLUE. IT
WOULD BE VERY EASY TO USE A
DEVICE THAT PAINLESSLY THROUGH
THE BLOOD FROM HER TWICE TODAY.
THESE DEVICES HAVE BEEN USED
OVER TWO MILLION TIMES IN THE
UNITED STATES. ONE MILLION TIMES
MICHAEL BOTTOM IS SO THEY ARE
SAFE. AND THEY ARE THEY ARE-
HAVE BEEN WELL USED AND PROVEN
SO. WITH THAT. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR WENT. C.
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE TO
ROLLING TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP. I BELIEVE I WANTED
SOMEONE TO TAKE A SEVEN ITEM BUT
WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE
MOMENTARILY. THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
INDEED GOING TO JUMP TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE. AND
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE ZERO SEVEN SENATE
BILL FOR EIGHTEEN. AND THE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL FOR
EIGHTEEN BY CENTER LAYERED AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS DECLARE VIEWS
EITHER AFFECTED ME DEEPLY. MR
RIVAS YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- THIS IS AN
URGENTLY NEEDED DISTRICT BILL
THAT WILL KEEP THE WATER BILL-
THE COMMITTEE HOSPITAL OPEN
HOSPITAL IS THIS THIS HOSPITAL'S
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE- A
PROVIDER IN OUR REGION SURVEEN
LOW INCOME AND UNDER AN AND
UNINSURED POPULATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A HOSPITAL
IS SLATED TO CLOSE IF URGENT
ACTION IS NOT TAKEN IN RESPONSE
TO THE POTENTIAL CLOSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NGOS HAVE CALLED
FOR A NEW HEALTH CARE DISTRICT A
TWO CHOIRS HOSPITAL. THIS THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP CREATE
THIS NEW SPECIAL DISTRICT AND
DOES SO WITHOUT COSTING THE
STATE ANY MONEY. AND CONTAINS
ADDITIONAL AWESOME PROTECTIONS
IN CASE THE ACQUISITION- THAT IT
DOESN'T GO THROUGH AS PLANNED
AGAIN THIS HOSPITAL IS A CRUCIAL
LIFELINE FOR SO MANY UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. AND RESIDENTS IN
THE WATCHABLE REGION ON THE
CENTRAL COAST GOD THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
NO OPPOSITION- AND RESPECT US
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU THIS RIVAS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL. TIRED OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. IN
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE AND
TELEVOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION MISTER RIVAS REQUESTS
THE MEDIA TRANSMITTAL OF SENATE
BILL FOR EIGHTEEN TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP A FEW ADDITIONAL ITEMS. WHILE
WE'RE ALL HERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR. THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR STARTING WITH
MR MCCARTY. IN THIS FINAL SET OF
ITEMS. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE THIRTY TWO AND THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY MACKELLAR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO ESL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ADULTS SCHOOLS FOR BOTH
CREDIT AND NONCREDIT PROGRAMS
FOR OUR RECENT ARRIVALS
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
SOMETIMES HAVE TO PAY. OUT OF
STATE TUITION WHEN THEY FIRST
ARRIVED WHEN I FOCUS ON ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY AND GET THEIR LEG UP
IN OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WE
NEED THEM TO DO WELL WE NEED
THEM TO THRIVE THIS HELPS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO HELPS OUR
LOCAL EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS-
AND ROLL MORE STUDENTS WITH THAT
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY ONE. AB. TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY MISS BARRICADE
HAND CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAN AND
OTHERS NAPOLI THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MISTER K. HAND THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER NUMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS PASSED OUT OF ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS AFTER BECOMING A
TO YOUR BILL AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN PROHIBITS DIFFERENTIAL
PRICING ON THE BASIS OF GENDER
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE PINK TAX
THE PAYING TAXES THE ARBITRARILY
IMPOSE PRICE FOR BEING A WOMAN
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE STUDY
ESTIMATED THE YEAR AFTER YEAR A
TYPICAL CALIFORNIA WOMAN PAYS
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS MORE FOR THE
SAME GOODS AND SERVICES. THAN
HER MALE COUNTERPART THIS
ARBITRARILY PENALIZES WOMEN UP
TO FORTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR THAT IS THE TAX THAT WE PY
FOR BEING A WOMAN IT IS TIME
THAT WE GET RID OF IT AND WOMEN
HAVE BEEN HIT HARD IN THIS
PANDEMIC AND THE AND ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES THAT WE SEE ARE
INCREASED BY THIS DIFFERENTIAL
COST THE PAYING TAX AUG MEN'S
AND REINFORCES THE INEQUITIES
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE TRYING
TO FIX FOR WOMEN AND WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR K. AND MISS
GARCIA YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
IRATE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS THIS IS ONE OF
OUR- PRIORITY BILLS OUT THERE
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL- WE ARE.
UNDERPAID OVERWORKED UNDER
APPRECIATED AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT ALL WERE. TAX TO BEING BORN
A WOMAN SO IT'S LONG OVERDUE
THAT WE FIND SOME EQUITY. AND
RETAIL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. FAMOUS HERE SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. THIS PAIR OKAY HAVE YOU
MAY CLOSE WE WISH THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR TIME THAT. CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. WHERE IS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO MS
CERVANTES AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
CORKERY. SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CERVANTES AND OTHER FACULTY TO
ELECTIONS MISTER MANTAS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN WHICH WILL
CREATE AN INDEPENDENT CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BORDER
SUPERVISORS BEGINNING WITH THE
TWENTY THIRTY ROUND OF
REDISTRICTING WE AS MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT GET TO
DRAW OUR OWN DISTRICTS WHY
SHOULD THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BE ANY
DIFFERENT. IN EARLY DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTED FORTY
ONE TO A DOCTOR SUPERMAJORITY
DISTRICT MAP FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ROUND OF REDISTRICTING
THAT FRACTURED THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN OUR COUNTY DILUTING
THE COMMUNITIES VOTING POWER IN
THEIR CAPACITY TO LIKE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR CHOICE
I DO HOWEVER WORK HOWEVER WANT
TO COMMEND. FORMER OF THIS
POLICY. MANUEL THAT IS FOR TO
PROTECT RIGHTS IN JUNE A FAIR
REDISTRICTING. NONETHELESS THIS
FAILURE BY THE MAJORITY OF THE
BOARD TO PROTECT VOTING RIGHTS
AND COMPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW. ILLUSTRATES WHY AN
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION IS
NEEDED TO DRAW FAIR MAPS. AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN WILL CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION AND
RETURN THE POWER TO DRAW LINES
WHERE IT BELONGS WITH THE
CITIZENS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER
COMMISSIONS IN LA IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. L. THREE. MAKE A THIS
COMMISSION WOULD BE PROPORTIONAL
TO THE PARTISAN MAKEUP RIVERSIDE
COUNTY VOTERS INCLUDING THOSE
WITH NO PARTY PREFERENCE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SERVED AS
PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR CANDIDATES
FOR OFFICE IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
AS WELL AS THEIR IMMEDIATE
FAMILIES WOULD BE INELIGIBLE TO
SERVE. THE SAME WOULD BE TRUE
FOR POLITICAL SYCOPHANTS ALTON'S
FOR STATE LOCAL OR FEDERAL
LOBBYISTS THE GUIDELINES IN THIS
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT TRULY
INDEPENDENT FUND BY CITIZENS ARE
EMPOWERED TO DRAW SUPERVISOR-
DISTRICTS RIVERSIDE COUNTY IF
TWO OR ARE THE ARE MOST POPULOUS
COUNTIES IN THE STATE. ARE ABLE
TO DO THIS INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION. THE FOURTH LARGEST
COUNTY IN THE STATE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO SO AS WELL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THE RESTAURANT IS MISTER
MEDINA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN AND ONE TO ECHO THE
WORDS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
CORONA AND AS FOR AYE VOTE ON AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN SO THE
RESIDENTS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
COULD HAVE A MORE FAIR-
REPRESENTATION. OF THAN THEY GOT
FROM THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND THAT THE
LATINO COMMUNITY CAN BE CAPITAL
AS FOR AND I'VE VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN. GLOBAL. WHEN
WANTS TO ROLL OVER. THANK YOU
WHICH MEDINA. C. NOTIFICATION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. THIS
CERVANTES YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH
. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. CLICKABLE ROLL.
I'M A
RESERVE DESSERT ABOUT HOW
MEMBERS VOTERS- TO VOTE CLERK
WILL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED UP IS
FORTY NINE NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE B. THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE CORKERY. SOME AGO
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS NOT REALLY THE PUBLIC
PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS GARCIA AND
THANK YOU AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WOULD BAN THE SALE OF THAT
OPPOSED TO MINORS UNLESS
PRESCRIBED BY A DOCTOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. C. NOTIFICATION TO MAKE CLEAR
COOPER THEY'RE ALL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
THE CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOURS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE FOR
COREY SYMBOL THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA CLEAN%
AMERICA MR LEVINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD EXPAND
THE RIGHTS INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEWS TO ALL MEDICAL MEMBERS
REGARDLESS OF PLAN OR SERVICE AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW IS A
SECONDARY REVIEW OF THE DENIAL
OF A MEDICAL SERVICE BY AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL OF PHYSICIANS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE HAVE ACCESS
TO AYE AND MARS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE HOWEVER NOT ALL
MEDICARE MEMBERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO AN EXTERNAL APPEAL REVIEWED
BY CLINICAL EXPERTS I AM OUR
OPTION IS NOT AVAILABLE TO OVER
FOUR MILLION MEDIC CAL MEMBERS
ADDITIONALLY. MANY SERVICES ARE
NOT PROVIDED BY CERTAIN MEDICARE
PLANS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR IMR
INCLUDING SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH. MOST DENTAL SERVICES AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PROVIDED
THROUGH MEDICARE'S ALL OUR ACTS
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE WILL
BRING PARITY IN ACCESS TO AYE
EMAAR'S AMONGST THE MEDIC CAL
MEMBERS AND FOR SERVICES NOT
PROVIDED BY THE PLAN. AND
IMPROVE THE STATE FAIR HEARING
PROCESS THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LEVINE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM FOR CLUB THEY'RE ALL.
SERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WILL. DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF- I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK IN THE
FILE THE PICK UP FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN. AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
LEVIN FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON AND OTHERS
MACKLIN AND ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY MISTER PATTERSON. THANK
YOU UP MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS OF
THE BILL BEFORE YOU ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR PROVIDES A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR PROJECTS RECOMMENDED BY THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THAT IMPROVE THE FIRE
SAFETY OF EXISTING SUBDIVISIONS
THAT ARE LOCATED AT HIGHER VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES. AND WHO
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH EXIT ROUTES
TO GET RESIDENTS OUT SAFELY. A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THIS BILL
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY NINETEEN BY
THIS LEGISLATURE BUT WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR IS BEING A
PREMATURE HOWEVER WE NOW KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT NOW
MORE THAN EVER IN LIGHT OF THE
INCREASING NUMBER AND SEVERITY
OF FIRES THAT SWEEP ACROSS THE
STATE EACH YEAR. INCLUDING THE
CREEK FIRE THE DIXIE FIRE THE
CALDOR FIRED JUST TO NAME A FEW
. A MEMBERS THE BOARD HAS NOW
RELEASED SUBDIVISION REVIEWS
MAKING IT THE PERFECT TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY AND
PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE. I ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR IS A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION
THAT ENSURES PROJECTS IN THE
HIGH AND VERY HIGH SEVERITY
ZONES. CAN BE COMPLETED WITH THE
URGENCY IDENTIFIED BY THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY. THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK OF A
FASHION SCENE NOTICE I'M SORRY
MR COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZE. BERMAN
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THIS ISSUE OF EGRESS
IS VITALLY IMPORTANT. IT IS COME
SLOWLY ON OUR CONSCIOUSNESS
REMEMBER THE TERROR OF THE
OAKLAND HILLS FIRE OTHER FIRES
IN RECENT DECADES MY OF. CALLING
FROM THE FOOTHILLS AND I SHARE
REPRESENTATION OF A PATH OF
TRAVEL EGRESS ROUTE FOR THE
PEOPLE RANCHERIA TO INDICATE TO
SOMEBODY DISTRICT. IN AS MUCH AS
THE BEST AVAILABLE ROUTE
REQUIRES IN ACROSS A NARROW
BRIDGE AND HEAD TO THE
FAIRGROUNDS IN AMADOR COUNTY UP
THE ROAD- THIS IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO TAKE ACCOUNT
OF. AND DEFINITELY DRIVEN BY THE
INCREASE OF FIRES BUT LOOK AT
THESE FOR POTENTIAL. AS TO
SAFETY AND THE BOTTLE MEXICAN
PUT PEOPLE RISK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC INQUIRY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR DRIVERS. THANK
WHICH COOLEY. C. NOTIFICATION
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION CLERK WILL
OPEN ROLE. SERVICE ALL MEMBERS
ROOMS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE CEREMONY. WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL
FIRST TAKE A FILE I DON'T WANT
TO WAIT ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS. BURKE WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OF SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA RELATIVE
TO SRI LANKAN INDEPENDENCE DAY.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
. COAUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION
THIS IS FOR A CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NO THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OH SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA RELATIVE TO SRI LANKAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY. CRACKLE OF THE
WRONG CAN. THAT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY SEVEN THOSE
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDARS
ADOPTED. CLERK RE READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SOME PEOPLE SIX FORTY
NINE FIVE FIFTY SEVEN OH ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
I FIFTY SEVEN THOSE ZERO
POSSIBLE SEVEN SIXTY NINE HIGHS
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
EIGHT NINETY FIVE HIGHS FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SIXTEEN HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN THOSE
ARE A SIMPLE TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ICE FIFTY SEVEN THOSE ZERO
SYMBOL THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE I
FIFTY SEVEN THOSE ZERO SYMBOL
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR. HIGHS
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO IN A SYMBOL
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE HIGHS. FIFTY
SEVEN THOSE ZERO.
MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A GERMAN TO MEMORY. BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT. WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF UPCOMING ADDITIONAL
BIRTHDAYS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
RAMOS SAYS ON SATURDAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
AND MISTER RAMOSHAS CUPCAKES IN
THE LOUNGE. FY I YOU MAY WANT TO
CHECK THAT OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KEVIN KILEY HAPPY BIRTHDAY SIR
SUNDAY JANUARY THIRTIETH. NO
CUPCAKES SO. WE ARE MOVING TO
GERMAN TO MEMORY.
IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMAN TO
MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
AT THIS TIME. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANT PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MISS YOU WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMANY MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THE REGION IN MEMORY OF
CALIFORNIA BE FROM HUNTED BEACH.
LAST WEEK FEW WEEKS AGO THE
COMMUTER OF HUNTER BEACH IN
ORANGE COUNTY WAS SHOCKED AND
SADDENED BY THE SUDDEN DEATH. OF
KELLY EARNED BE AT AGE FORTY
SIX. A DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT HER FAMILY
COMMUNITY AND CALIFORNIA. BORN
AND RAISED IN SAN DIEGO KELLY
WAS THE DAUGHTER OF NAVY
VETERANS WHO IS DOING HER THE
LOVE OF COUNTRY AND SERVICE. SHE
WAS A GRADUATE OF UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO WHERE SHE RECEIVED HER
LAW DEGREE BEFORE BEING
RECRUITED TO GET TO A LOCAL
PRIVATE PRACTICE. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SHE JOINED THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AS A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AND WORK AS
PART OF THE- C. D. A.'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION TEAM.
KELLY WAS WIDELY RESPECTED BY
HER COLLEAGUES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
EXPANSION FOR HER WORK WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW. THE PASSION
FOR THE LAW AND PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S NET NATURAL. BEAUTY
AND TREASURE WAS REFLECTED IN
HER WORK DRAFTING ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT MANUALS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SHE RECEIVED AN AWARD
FROM HER PEERS RECOGNIZING HER.
FOR SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT. KELLY
WILL BE REMEMBERED BY HER
FRIENDS. THE FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES AND SUPPORTERS AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS VERY PASSIONATE.
ABOUT HER LOVE FOR POLITICS FOR
AMERICA AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY. KELLY IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND AXEL. WHO WE SEND OUR
PRAYERS AND THOUGHTS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. HEY MISS WHEN DR CHOI
YOUR RETINA. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBERS NOT TODAY I RISE
UP TO A JOHN NOW IN THE MEMORY
OUTBOX KELLY EARNED THE WHOLE
PASSED AWAY ON MONDAY JANUARY
THIRD OF. AT THE YA TRAGICALLY
YOUNG AGE UPPER SIX KELLY
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE LIFE OF
TO A PUBLIC SERVICE- INCLUDING A
MORE THAN A DECADE DOUBLES AS
SO- ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHERE SHE
WORKED A PROBLEM ALREADY OUR-
OWN ENVIRONMENTAL. AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION CASES. SHE ALSO
SERVED ON THE ORANGE COUNTY AND
ARMY DON'T LAW ENFORCEMENT TASK
FORCE. THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SECTION OF THE CALIFORNIA.
CONSUMER PROTECTION COUNCIL AND
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY CONSUMER
PROTECTION TASK FORCE. KELLY WAS
THE BOROUGH OF THE TWO NAVY
VETERANS SAW AND A SISTER TO A
MARINE SHE GRADUATED FROM-
TWENTY TOUGHEST ALLAH. HIGH IN
CHULA VISTA IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE EARNED HER BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN THE BIOLOGICAL
SCIENCES SO FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA. HER LAW THREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
HER MASTERS IN PUBLIC.
ADMINISTRATION FROM USC. IN
ADDITION HER PROFESSION- AS O.
ORANGE. PROP KELLY- SOLD IMPROVE
HER. BY HER TIME AND- ENERGY
SUPPORTING LEADERS AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND THE FEDERAL OFFICE
INCLUDING AS A VOLUNTEER-
ORDINATOR. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
GOP CENTRAL COMMITTEE I WAS
IMPRESSED BY HER GENUINE SPIRIT
AND A PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE
. HER LEGACY OF ALL FIGHTING
TOOL SUPPORT TO WORKING FAMILIES
PROTECT NO. TIME VICTIMS ARE AND
THE IMPROVEORANGE COUNTY WILL
NOT BE FORGOTTEN THANK YOU.
LATER CHOI MS DAVIS YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY COME
BEFORE YOU TO HONOR A VIBRANT
WOMAN WHO IS NO LONGER WITH US
KELLY R. AND B. KELLY WAS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND AXEL AND
BE LOVED DOGS SHE WAS FORTY SIX
YEARS OLD AND TAKEN AWAY TOO
SOON. I WAS BLESSED TO KNOW
KELLY MY FRIEND AND IN MY READ
HER ENERGETIC PASSION FOR
POLITICS I BELIEVE THE DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN ORANGE
COUNTY- BE HAD NINETEEN YEARS OF
LEGAL EXPERIENCE INCLUDING MORE
THAN A DECADE THAT ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY DA WHERE SHE WORKED
PRIMARILY ON ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES
SHE ALSO SERVED ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TASKFORCE THE SEVEN
SECTION OF CALVET SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
COUNCIL. AND THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY CONSUMER PROTECTION
TASK FORCE BEFORE JOINING THE
DA'S OFFICE SHE WORKED FOR A
PRIVATE ORANGE COUNTY FIRM
HANDLING CIVIL BUSINESS
LITIGATION FOR NINE YEARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY KELLY RAN FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS AN
ORANGE COUNTY REPUBLICAN CENTRAL
COMMITTEE HER BID FOR ASSEMBLY
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL HOWEVER SHE WON
A SEAT ON THE CENTRE COMMITTEE
HELD A QUICKLY BECAME PART OF
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM AND HEADED
UP. THE PRECINCT OPERATIONS HER
LEADERSHIP AND PASSION FOR
REPUBLICAN POLICY PRINCIPLES
GREW THE PRECINCTS OPERATION
QUICKLY AND KELLY SUCCESSFULLY
RECRUITED OVER SIX HUNDRED
VOLUNTEERS I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE
BY READING A VERSE IN PROVERBS
THIRTY TWO TWENTY NINE THIS
FIRST TRULY REFLECTS KELLY'S
CHARACTER STRENGTH AND PASSION
FOR EVERYTHING SHE DID. MANY
WOMEN DO NOBLE THINGS BUT TO
SUPPRESS. THE MALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER. MR MEDINA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF Y GOOD FRIEND
JENNIFER VON BLAKELY WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY SIXTEENTH IN
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA. JENNIFER
WAS A LONG TIME COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE AND PAST ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER. IN THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE IT WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO BE CITY
MANAGER IN THE CITY OF FONTANA.
JENNIFER WAS TRULY CUT FROM A
DIFFERENT CLOTH ONE OF SERVICE
AND HUMILITY. WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY AND VERY IS FAITH
BASED AGENCIES HELP TO ESTABLISH
MULTIPLE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE GROUP A GRASSROOTS
PUBLIC POLICY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING
COMMUNITY ISSUES THAT IMPACTS
RIVERSIDE'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. WHEN I FIRST DECIDED
TO RUN FOR OFFICE IT WAS THAT
THE GROUP THAT I FIRST ANNOUNCED
MY CANDIDACY FOR THE ASSEMBLY IN
TWENTY TWELVE. AND THEIR SUPPORT
MEANT SO MUCH TO ME. JENNIFER
WAS A MODEL OF CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY SHE ALWAYS
CONDUCTED HERSELF WITH THE
UTMOST INTEGRITY PROFESSIONALISM
AND THE HIGHEST ETHICAL
STANDARDS. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF HONORING
JENNIFER AS A WOMAN OF
DISTINCTION FOR HER WORK AND
PASSION FOR SERVICE. HER
TIRELESS ENERGY AND COMMITMENT
WAS AN INSPIRATION TO ALL OF US
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE. SHE WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED JENNIFER IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND ANTHONY
BLAKELY AND HER SON ANTHONY THE
SECOND. I ASKED THAT WE A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY A JENNIFER
BONDS BLAKELY. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN MEMORY
OF ENGINEER DAVID SPANK WHO
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY NINTH.
THIS YEAR. DAVID SPEAK WITH THE
THIRTY TWO YEAR VETERAN OF THE
BARSTOW FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
. IN DECEMBER HE WAS HIT BY A
FAST MOVING VEHICLE ON
INTERSTATE FIFTEEN. WHILE THEY
WERE RESPONDING TO AN ACCIDENT
EARLIER. I ASK ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO PLEASE SLOW DOWN AND MOVE
OVER WHEN THERE'S PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL. ATTENDING TO AN
ACCIDENT. MISTER SPEX STARTED
HIS CAREER IN NINETEEN NINETY
WITH THE BARSTOW FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT AS A PAID CALL
FIREFIGHTER. AND WAS LATER
PROMOTED TO FULL TIME IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE. OVER THE
SPAN OF HIS CAREER. ENGINEERS
MAKE WORKED AT BOTH STATIONS IN
BARSTOW. DAVID IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE COLEEN. HIS FATHER WALT
BROTHERS LOGAN AND RYAN IN A
CERTAIN DOLLAR. WHO IS ALSO A
BARSTOW FIREFIGHTER. HE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED PLEASE KEEP THAT
FAMILY IN YOUR PRAYERS AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS SMITH MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MR SIDNEY
POTIER. MISTER PARTY A WAS AN
EIGHTY FIFTY CONSTITUENTS
ACTIVIST DIPLOMAT AND LEGENDARY
HOLLYWOOD ACTOR KNOWN FOR HIS
POIGNANT DISTINGUISHED ROLES IN
TRAILBLAZING FILMS ABOUT RACE
AND SOCIAL ISSUES. HE PASSED
AWAY EARLIER THIS MONTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR. SYDNEY
POTIER WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. IN MIAMI BUT GREW UP IN
NASSAU BEFORE EMIGRATING TO THE
UNITED STATES. HE WAS FIFTEEN
WHEN HE JOINED EXTENDED FAMILIES
IN FLORIDA. IF IT IN FLORIDA
BEFORE MOVING ON TO NEW YORK
CITY. WHICH HE FELT TO BE MORE
TOLERABLE THAN JIM CROW FLORIDA.
IN NEW YORK PARDEE A HOPE TO
PURSUE ACTING WHILE WORKING AS A
DISHWASHER. HE FAILED IN HIS
FIRST ACTING AUDITION DUE TO A
LANGUAGE BARRIER AND INABILITY
TO READ THE SCRIPT. BUT AN
ELDERLY JEWISH WAITER READ THE
NEWSPAPER WITH A YOUNG PARTY A
SEVERAL NIGHTS A WEEK TO IMPROVE
HIS LITERACY. AT SIXTEEN FORTY A
LIED ABOUT HIS AGE TO ENLIST IN
THE ARMY DURING WORLD WAR TWO
WHERE HE WAS ASSIGNED. TO A
VETERANS HOSPITAL IN NEW YORK TO
WORK WITH PATIENTS ON THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. UPON DISCOVERING
HOW POORLY PATIENTS SUFFERED
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS WERE
TREATED. HE WAS DISGUSTED AND
FAKED AN ILLNESS TO BE
DISCHARGED. UPON LEAVING THE
ARMY HE RETURNED TO ACTING AND
CO FOUNDED AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WAS CENTERED ON LEFT WING
ANALYSISOF CLASS AND RACIAL
EXPLOITATION. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
WHAT THE A WAS OFFERED HIS FIRST
FILM ROLE IN NO WAY OUT A FILM
NOIR DIRECTED BY THE FAMED
JOSEPH MICHAELIS WHO CAST PARTY
A WERE HIS EMOTIONAL INTENSITY
AND GRACE PLAYING A DOCTOR IN AN
URBAN HOSPITAL. THE FILM
DESCRIBED AS A GRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION OF RACIAL. SET A
PRECEDENT FOR PARTY AS FUTURE
FILM ROLES THAT WOULD
CONSISTENTLY TACKLE RACE AND
SOCIAL ISSUES HEAD ON IN
MAINSTREAM AMERICAN CINEMA.
LAURIER CONTINUE TO BE CAST IN
MAJOR FILMS AND IN NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT HE STARRED ALONG
TONY CURTIS IN THE DEFIANT ONES.
WHERE HE BECAME THE FIRST BLACK
MAN TO BE NOMINATED FOR BEST
ACTOR. CONTINUING ON THIS
TRAJECTORY PARTY IT WAS GOOD IT
WAS CAST IN LILIES IN THE FIELD
IN WHICH HE BECAME THE FIRST
BLACK MAN TO WIN AN ACADEMY
AWARD FOR BEST ACTOR. AND
CEMENTING HIS ROLE IN HOLLYWOOD
HISTORY AS THE FIRST BLACK MAN
TO ACHIEVE THIS HONOR. BY
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN PARDEE A
WITH THE BIGGEST BOX OFFICE DRAW
WITH HIS LANDMARK RULES IN THE
SIR WITH LOVE GUESS WHO'S COMING
TO DINNER. AND IN THE HEAT OF
THE NIGHT. MAJOR HOLLYWOOD FILMS
THAT ALL DEALT WITH THE RACIAL
DIVIDE IN AMERICA. IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES PARTY I GOT
BEHIND THE CAMERA DIRECTED
SEVERAL SUCCESSFUL COMEDIES ANY
CONTINUED ACTING AND DIRECTING
INTO THE EIGHTIES AND NINETIES
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN HE WAS
APPOINTED AMBASSADOR FROM THE
BAHAMAS TO JAPAN. A POSITION
THAT HE HELD UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. SIMULTANEOUSLY HE SERVED
AS THE AMBASSADOR OF THE BAHAMAS
TO UNESCO. WHAT IT WAS THE
RECIPIENT OF MULTIPLE ACADEMY
GRAMMY AND GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS
QUEEN ELIZABETH THE SECOND NIGHT
AT HIM IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA HONORED HIM
WITH THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE HE WAS AWARDED
WITH THE HONORARY ACADEMY AWARD
FOR HIS OVERALL CONTRIBUTION TO
AMERICAN CINEMA. VANITY FAIR
DESCRIBED PARTY A AS THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING OF CINEMA. WELL THE
NEW YORK TIMES SAID HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL THE HOLLYWOOD STAR
VERSATILITY AND PAVING THE WAY
FOR BLACK ACTORS EVERYWHERE.
SEVERAL JOURNALISTS AND FILM
CRITICS DUB CRITICS DUBBED HIM
THE FIRST OF FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN FILM STAR. FIDDLY PARTY
A PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY SIXTH
AT HIS HOME IN BEVERLY HILLS AND
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
JOANNA SHIMKUS AND FIVE OF HIS
SIX DAUGHTERS AND I ASK. THAT
THIS BODY ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
THANK YOU MEMBERS SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST FLOOR NO
SESSION NO CHECK IN MONDAY
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST FOUR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WE PASADENA
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING
AND HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS
ALREADY TURNITIN EMOTIONAL
INJURE. MISTER BLOOM MOVES AND
MISS VALID THERE SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL
MONDAY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST AT
ONE PM WE ARE TURNED.
AB FIVE
TWENTY TWO I DO NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN WILL CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TWENTY TWO I DO NOT LOOKING
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ VOTE CHANGE AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FROM I CANNOT VOTING. PRO
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
SOME PEOPLE ELEVEN TWENTY ALL
RIGHT TO NOT VOTING. MODE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY I DO NOT VOTING.
WILL CHANGE IN THE SUMMER MEDINA
ASSEMBLY ELEVEN TWENTY- INTO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FELLOW THERE IS
AB THREE ONE THREE ZERO SEVEN NO
TO NOT VOTING WILL CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALID THERE IS
SOME WIGGLE THIRTEEN OH SEVEN NO
TURNOUT VOTING.